bueno la noticia corrió como un reguero
o sea es titular en todos los medios
varias notas dándole cobertura a esta
historia en los grupos de chat donde
ahora también se comparten rápidamente
las noticias apareció esta información
con Mucho peso con mucha fuerza empiezan
los recuerdos No necesariamente una
noticia sorprendente ustedes ya
estuvieron hablando de esto Pelé estaba
enfermo hubo muchas informaciones
hablando de que se deterioraba su salud
y eso es algo que también se sabía en
Argentina Pero por supuesto en Argentina
las reacciones también están vinculadas
por un lado con la historia lo que
estamos escuchando recién en el especial
de France 24 sobre la historia de Pelé
Quién es Pelé su vínculo con el fútbol
su historia y su y su crecer en Brasil
pero acá también hay un elemento más la
eterna rivalidad Argentina Brasil le da
un condimento extra la cobertura y
también hay un enfoque orientado ese
vínculo entre Argentina y Brasil y
específicamente entre Diego Armando
Maradona y
le pregunto también natalio como será
recordado Pelé en Argentina un país que
pues lo veníamos hablando durante todo
este especial ha sido muy importante en
la carrera por esta rivalidad que había
entre Pelé y Maradona Qué piensan
Entonces los argentinos y cómo lo van a
recordar
Bueno hay un lado que tiene que ver con
el folclore del fútbol la rivalidad la
chanza las burlas que estaban en la
historia de ambos países cuando Maradona
y Pelé Maradona y falleció hace dos años
ambos estaban vivos bueno Estaba muy
presente en las hinchadas el señalar a
uno y al otro típico del folklore del
fútbol que también se alimentaba de una
rivalidad que era amor odio entre
Maradona y pelé porque se han dicho
muchas cosas cosas duras uno al otro
pero también se han acercado mucho y se
recordó mucho ahora en Argentina estuvo
circulando mucho por esta por esto de la
referencialidad hacia Argentina de la de
la noticia esa invitación que le hizo
Diego Armando Maradona un programa de
televisión que se llamó la noche del 10
allá por 2005 si no recuerdo mal
Pelé fue invitado a ese programa Y
estuvieron juntos y fue un gran
encuentro de dos grandes grandes ídolos
del fútbol dos de los más grandes de la
historia algunos más grande en Argentina
seguramente dirán Maradona tal vez ahora
mes y después de haber ganado la copa
del mundo pero ahí hubo una interacción
muy linda entre dos hombres que se
conocían muy bien que entendían muy bien
Quién era el otro y es muy recordado un
jueguito de cabeza que hicieron entre
los dos que Maradona le dijo que era
algo que él tenía muchas ganas de hacer
así que es un vínculo curioso en el que
el folklore del fútbol se asentó muchas
veces en la rivalidad y en las cosas que
se decían pero también una admiración
mutua y sin duda acá es reconocido Pelé
como un grande grande del fútbol